vamos acompañando a María Fátima
Valencia Ella es la abuela de los niños
que sufrieron un accidente el primero de
mayo en el que perdieron a su madre y
que actualmente está el país volcado en
su búsqueda Doña Fátima que es lo último
que han sabido de los niños
puesto un momento Buenos días mi nombre
es Mario Fátima Valencia
es tu momento pues los niños ellos lo
miran los huellas de que yo duerme o de
que yo mantiene Entonces estos momentos
Pues
necesitamos de verdad un relevo Los
Paisanos porque todo esto lo situaciones
lo encontraron los paisanos de nosotros
Y ahora yo necesito meter otro rapidito
necesito urgente para que busque eso los
niños se siente ya agotado Hasta no ver
mis nietos no voy a estar contento no
voy a respirar
en todo el país está pendiente el mundo
entero
hay esperanza de encontrar los vivos
Usted cree que están vivos Sí yo creo
porque en otro tenemos una cultura de
verdad que creemos a mi Dios y la virgen
Guadalupe no tiene que acompañar cuando
llegue aquí nosotros la parte los lo que
somos la tía los tíos vamos a estar
contento pues ya Gracias mi Dios pues ya
mi hija se fue ya ella no va a sufrir ya
el que vamos a sufrir son nosotros y ese
recuerdo de mi hija que quedará mi nieto
entonces yo necesito este grande país el
doctor Petro también que no apoye con
los ejércitos porque es muy duro para mí
Muchas gracias María Fátima y Seguiremos
informando con nuevas novedades sobre el
rescate de los cuatro niños